if you're working on a brand-new machine
learning application one of the piece of
advice I often give people is that I
think you should build your first system
quickly and then iterate let me show you
what I mean I've worked on speech
recognition for many years and if you're
thinking of building a new speech
recognition system they're actually a
lot of directions you could go in a lot
of things you could prioritize for
example there's the SiC techniques for
making speech recognition systems more
robust to a noisy background and noisy
background could mean carefully noise
like a lot of people talking in the
background or car noise the sound of
calls and highways or other types of
noise there are ways to make a speech
recognition system more robust to
accented speech there are specific
problems associated with speakers that
are far from the microphone this is
called fast speech recognition young
children's speech poses special
challenges both in terms of how they
pronounce individual words as well as
their choice of words and vocabulary
they tend to use and if sometimes your
speaker status or if they use
nonsensical phrases like oh ah um you
know there are different choices and
different techniques so I'm making the
transcript that you output still beat
more fluently so there are these and
many other things you could do to
improve the speech recognition system
and more generally for almost any
machine learning application there could
be 50 different directions you could go
in and each of these directions is
reasonable and would make your system
better but the challenge is how do you
pick which of these to focus on and even
though I've worked in speech recognition
for many years if I'm building a new
system for a new application domain I
would still find it maybe a little bit
difficult to pick without spending some
time thinking about the problem so when
we recommend you do if you're starting
on building a brand new machine learning
application is to go to first system
quickly and then iterate what I mean by
that is I recommend that you first
quickly set up a definition and metrics
so this is really you know deciding
where to place your target
and you get it wrong you can always move
it later we just set up a target
somewhere and then I recommend you build
an initial machine learning system
quickly find the training set train it
and see start to see and understand how
well you're doing against your Devon
chess setting evaluation metric when you
build your initial system you then be
able to use bias variance analysis we
should talk about earlier as well as
error analysis which we talked about
just in last several videos to
prioritize the next step in particular
if error analysis causes you to realize
that a lot of the errors are from the
speaker being very far from the
microphone which causes special
challenges speech recognition then that
would give you a good reason to focus on
techniques to address this is called
fast used speech recognition which
basically means handling when the
speaker is very far from the microphone
along the value of building this initial
system it can be a quick and dirty
implementation
you know don't overthink it but all the
value of the initial system is having
some learn system having some train
system allows you to look at bias and
variance to try to prioritize what to do
next
allows you to do error analysis look at
some mistakes to figure out all the
different directions you could go in
which ones are actually the most
worthwhile so to recap what about when
you do is there's your first system
quickly then iterate this advice applies
less strongly if you're working on an
application area in which you have
significant prior experience it also
applies to the less strongly if there's
a significant body of academic
literature that you can draw on for
pretty much the exact same problem
you're building so for example there's a
large academic literature on face
recognition and if you're trying to
build a face recognizer it might be okay
to build a more complex system from the
get-go by building on this large body of
academic literature but if you're
tackling a new problem for the first
time then I would encourage you to
really not overthink or not make your
first system
- complicated which has build something
quick and dirty and then use that to
help you prioritize how to improve your
system so I've seen a lot of machine
learning projects and I've seen some
teams overthink their solution and don't
get me too complicated I've also seen
some things under thinking and build
something maybe too simple but on
average I've seen a lot more teams
overthink and build something too
complicated and I've seen teams you know
build something too simple so I hope
this helps and if you are applying to
your machine learning algorithms to a
new application and if you main goal is
to build something that works um as
opposed to if you main goes to invent a
new machine learning algorithm which is
a different goal the remain goes to get
something that works really well I'd
encourage you to build something quick
and dirty use that to do bivariate
analysis use that to do error analysis
and you see results of those analysis
that helps you prioritize where to go
next
you